angle so what exactly is the
circumcenter well the circumcenter is
where the three perpendicular bisectors
cross or intersect so just to give you a
rough idea here perpendicular means that
it's at a right angle bisector means
that it bisects or cuts the side in half
so for example if we want to bisect the
side right here we'd have to find the
midpoint and we'd have to draw a line
that's perpendicular meaning at a right
angle then what we can do is go to the
other side of the triangle find the
midpoint again and find the
perpendicular okay to that side and then
if we same thing with the third side if
we find the midpoint and then draw a
line that's perpendicular if everything
goes well here in my diagram they should
all cross at the common point of
intersection which is called the
circumcenter and the significance of the
circumcenter is is that you can think of
this as the center of a circle if you
measure the distance to any one of the
three vertices it's going to be the same
meaning that you can circumscribe or
draw a circle around the triangle such
that the vertices of the triangle are on
the circle but the basic thing that
we're gonna be doing here is finding the
equations of two of the perpendicular
bisectors we're gonna find out where
those two equations cross that point is
going to be the circumcenter this center
of the circle here so let's go ahead and
jump into this particular example here
the first thing I want to do is I want
to find the midpoint of side ad so I'm
just going to denote theta that is
capital M sub ad so the midpoint of
segment a B now when you find the
midpoint what you want to do is you want
to find the average of the x's and the
average of the Y's so what we do is we
add the XS together negative 4 plus 2
and we divide by 2 same thing with the Y
coordinates we take the Y's and we add
them together 2 plus 4 and we divide by
2 so just think of it like an average
like if you get an 80% and a hundred
percent you add those together divided
by 2 that's gonna be your average right
so here we've got negative 2 divided by
2 which is negative 1/2 plus 4 is 6
divided by 2 is 3 so the midpoint here
should be a negative 1 positive 3 ok now
my drawings you know a little bit off I
just did this freehand but that's going
to be the midpoint here now we want to
do is we want to find the Perkin
dick Euler to this side a B so we have
to find the slope of a B so I'm gonna do
no theta with a lowercase M for slope so
the slope of side a B and to find the
slope we do the y2 minus y1 over x2
minus x1 the slope formula so we do 4
minus 2 over 2 minus negative 4
remember when you subtract it's like
adding the opposite so this is going to
give us 2/6 which is 1/3 now if we find
the perpendicular okay so I didn't order
that with the perpendicular symbol we
have to take the opposite reciprocal so
I'm going to change the stuff negative
since this is positive and I'm going to
flip it over that's going to give it us
negative 3 so we know that the slope is
negative 3 and it goes through the
midpoint here which is negative 1/3 so
if we put that together into an equation
using the point-slope formula we have Y
minus 3
so Y minus the y-coordinate equals the
slope which is negative 3 times X minus
the x-coordinate well X minus a negative
1 is like X plus 1 now I can simplify
this a little bit further by
distributing that gives us negative 3x
minus 3 and if I add 3 that's 3 over
here to both sides that's going to give
us y equals negative 3x the negative 3
and the positive 3 cancel so we're
getting y equals negative 3x so what
that means is the y-intercept is 0 it's
going right here through the origin so
the line is gonna look something like
this okay I'm just rough sketching right
here ok so that's the equation of one of
the perpendicular bisectors so bisected
cut that in half and it was
perpendicular okay so now what we need
to do is find the slope and the midpoint
of this side BC so let's go ahead and
find the midpoint first so the midpoint
of BC we're going to take the average of
the axis so 2 plus 4 divided by 2 and
we're gonna take the average of the Y's
4 plus negative 4 divided by 2 so that
slope I'm sorry not that slope but the
midpoint comes out to 6 over 2 which is
3/4 plus negative 4 is 0 over 2 which is
0 so it looks like the midpoint is gonna
be here at 3 comma 0
okay so midpoint
we want to find the slope of BC so we're
gonna use our slope formula so slope of
BC that equals y2 minus y1 is so 4 minus
negative 4 over x2 minus x1 so 2 minus 4
so that comes out to 8 over negative 2
which is negative 4 but the slope of the
perpendicular to BC is going to be the
opposite reciprocal so I'm going to flip
that over and change the sign so it's
going to be 1/4 so if we take the point
3 0 and a slope of 1/4 put that together
using our point-slope form this is going
to be Y minus the y-coordinate equals
the slope times X minus the x-coordinate
we get y equals 1/4 X minus 3/4 so now
let's go ahead and draw that line in
here so this is going to be a slope of
negative 3/4 so that's going to be let's
see y-intercept of negative 3/4 is
somewhere right around here and a slope
of rise 1 run for something around here
so it looks like it's going to go
something like that ok so it looks like
they're crossing right here but let's go
use the algebra to find that common
point of intersection so we're going to
go ahead and do a substitution if y
equals negative 3x I'm going to put
negative 3x in place of Y so let me
write that over here so negative 3 x
equals 1/4 X minus 3/4 now here's the
thing a lot of times when students get a
lot of fractions you know they get a
little bit intimidated but since we have
a common denominator of 4 like like this
is over 1/4 for fours like our common
denominator I'm going to multiply
everything by 4 to clear the fractions
so 4 times negative 3 gives us negative
12x 4 times 1/4 is 1 so that's just X
and then these fours are gonna cancel
that just gives us minus 3 so if I
subtract X from both sides I get
negative 13 x equals negative 3 divide
will sides by negative 13 x equals 3 13
if I take 3 13s and I put it back in
either into this equation or this
equation I'll do this one so it's a
little bit easier negative 3 times 3 3
Keane's gives us negative nine thirteen
so three thirteen comma negative nine
thirteen that's going to be our common
point of intersection of our two
perpendicular bisectors and that's going
to be our circumcenter so let's see if
that's accurate here we've got three
thirteen okay negative nine thirteen so
pretty pretty good you know pretty close
okay my diagram is a little bit off
because the spacing of the x and y scale
but not exactly perfect like on graph
paper right but that's how you would do
it algebraically so if you want to see
how to do this using constructions with
a compass and a protractor and a
straightedge and all that go ahead and
check out the video I did right there
great job if you like the way that I
teach and you're interested in learning
more about algebra geometry algebra 2
precalculus a CT math SAT math check out
more videos on my Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel and I'll see you in the
other videos I'll talk to you then